saviez vous que le revenu universel est
un concept qui datent de 1516 à cette
époque l'humaniste anglais thomass mort
décrit une société ou un revenu de
subsistance était assurée pour tous de
la naissance à la mort indépendamment du
travail
une utopie repris ensuite par des
philosophes ou des économistes et même
dans les années 90 par des chefs
d'entreprises français ce serait quoi
par exemple le revenu d'existence revenu
d'existence pour reprendre de l'ambré
sont ces rémunérer les personnes parce
qu'elles existent et non pour exister et
sur la base du revenu d'existence les
personnes pour air développer des
revenus d'activité mais dans une société
plurielle et plus uniquement centrée
uniquement sur l'emploi salarié une
société ou un revenu de subsistance
serait assurée où le travail ne serait
pas une finalité en soi une théorie
idéaliste diront certains une obligation
pour ce collectif de chômeurs européens
parmi les revendications communes autres
pays la plus importante
un revenu de base pour la dignité
équivalent à 1200 euros soit 7200 francs
afin de participer pleinement à la vie
sociale culturelle et politique de
l'europe
le temps passe et l'utopie devient un
programme politique
on propose un revenu universel pour que
tous les gens même s'ils perdent leur
emploi puis c'est vers ça c'est quoi il
faut qu'on ait un revenu qui soit
supérieur au revenu minimum qui
permettent au genre dès l'âge de 18 ans
parce que les jeunes sont très concernés
de pouvoir vivre décemment
cinq ans plus tard même programme de
politique européenne
mais du côté du parti de christine
boutin
proposons la création d'un revenu de
base européen qui empêche européen
gilbert européen et empêche à tous de ne
jamais tomber dans l'extrême précarité
des 1017 le revenu universel devient
même l'argument principal de campagne de
benoît hamon candidat à la primaire de
la gauche
la révolution numérique va nous amener à
ce que le travail soit plus rare et le
revenu universel permet de choisir de
réduire son temps de travail parce qu'on
sait qu'on ne perdra pas de pouvoir
d'achat mais le candidat à la
présidentielle sera obligé de
transformer son idée de revenu universel
en un revenu de base
fusionnant les aides sociales et
uniquement à destination des plus
pauvres
bien loin du projet de base qui
concernait tout le monde
benoît hamon présenté aujourd'hui son
programme on parle moins du revenu
universel et un peu plus du travail et
de l'emploi le revenu universel
un concept philosophique un idéal
économique
un programme politique une association
française
le mouvement français pour le revenu de
base défend le projet le sénat lui en a
fait un rapport
bref le taupe y gagnent du terrain
lentement
[Musique]